hey everybody would you believe it
we're back with another episode of wild
ride with stevo and this one's special
because
i have been performing in comedy clubs
for
over a decade now and whenever i've been
in the comedy club
and kevin nelen takes the stage
i am just giddy because he's so
incredible man
and that's all i want to say enjoy this
one because he is a legend of saturday
night live
he is a legend of stand-up comedy and
here he is ladies and gentlemen kevin
nehelen
yeah dude yeah thank you thank you very
much hey thank you
i would like to introduce you to my
co-host scott randolph how you doing
kevin
scott we're both huge fans of yours you
might also
hear a voice coming from off camera that
is paul briskey
hey kevin how are you hey paul oh it
sounds like paul
yeah that's me all right he's got
everybody's got nicknames
um paul is young [ __ ]
that's this that's his name ed scott is
international star
i've been everywhere we really are big
fans and uh it's an honor to have you so
so thank you every time i go into one of
these
it seems i want to do some research and
i just
feel like a stalker you know like how
about that i've been
i've been stalking you online and
uh and i feel creepy for that but
but i'm filled with questions as as we
all are
and we're dying to know about this
wiretapping situation
first of all where are you right now
we're actually uh in the hollywood hills
you know you're traveling all over the
country then huh
we do you probably passed it while
you're doing your hiking show we're kind
of close to the area where you usually
go
it may be yeah so um which wiretapping
are you talking about right there were
two wiretapping things that we read
about
one now i mean i said that we have this
in common where we're uh
animal rights people we we love animals
that's right
yeah thank god i've got wendy this is
wendy i rudely didn't introduce her
oh hi wendy yeah so so it had to do with
animal activism one of these wiretaps
well one of them one of them did
the other one had to do with a um a case
between my friend gary chandling
and our manager uh brad gray where he
we were being wiretapped by um
um a private investigator that was hired
by um
somebody's lawyer wow and one and i
always kind of felt like we were being
wiretapped because i could hear the
tapping
i think gary sounds like we're being
wiretapped everybody's listening to us
enjoy you know i feel like that was
maybe a bad first question because here
we are we're already into the weeds
yeah so um
yeah so but he went to prison i'm
flanking on his name right now
but he went to prison he just got out a
couple months ago
uh how about about 10 years or whatever
i don't know
wow was it the end of his sentence or
was it like a coveted release
got you oh trump trump pardoned him
[Laughter]
no um he um yeah so he's out now and um
um and then the other wiretapping
apparently allegedly was
from barnum bailey circus because i had
been doing some protests with animal
rights groups
and um they were trying to um you know
undermine us or whatever right my career
began as a circus clown
i went to the room yeah i went to the
ringling brothers and barnum and bailey
clown
college which was very prestigious to
get into
but while we were there and i have this
crazy memory
um in cloud college there was a uh
a visit from the the public relations
department of the ringling brothers and
barnum and billy circus and they said
congratulations on making it into clown
college now some of you are going to
work for the
the greatest show on earth the ringling
brothers and barnum and billy circus
and what that's going to uh in in entail
is a lot of press you know that you're
going to go and advance the circus to
and when you're doing interviews some
people are going to ask you about animal
abuse in the circus
and if and when that happens they said
you shut up
you have no opinion you fall down you're
a clown
you your job is not to to speak on this
and i remember thinking man there
that the the way they're talking about
this it seems like they're this circus
is doing something wrong with animals
that was where that was where my journey
began and i too
uh spoke out against animals in the
circus
uh you know for a pita there was a
public public service announcement a
campaign
and maybe um i was being wiretapped but
um
it was hard to tell because i was on so
many drugs
yeah there's all kinds of hallucinations
going on like uh
there's a lot of crazy stuff happening i
i wouldn't i
think did you end up working for the
circus uh
i didn't work for the ringling circus um
the uh they didn't want me they said we
need you to wire tap kevin nealon
right i didn't work you ended up working
for circus vargas in
las vegas now i i am a fan of circus
vargas and
my old boss clown from clown college uh
was the the head clown for from that he
ran that whole show
but now i worked for a different circus
at a flea market
in south florida uh true story it was a
flea market
and um or tampa not fort lauderdale
and it was the it was called the
hannaford family circus
at the fort lauderdale swap shop and
they i do believe got shut down
for animal abuse they had these three
elephants and a tiger
and my first hand uh experience
i felt that those animals were in a
terrible situation so i applaud you
kevin
thank you buddy yeah you too man you
know i think every kid wanted to go to
clown school at one point or another
yeah but you actually did it so that's
pretty cool yeah but yeah i mean it's
obvious the uh the abuse that those
animals uh suffered and
obvious now they don't even use
elephants anymore i think and all those
circuses i think are shut down
right they the ringling brothers went
out of business completely
there is no more ringling brothers
circus and i don't know that they're
at least in america i don't think there
are any circuses that have animals
anymore
no i mean i love cirque du soleil yeah
they're going out of business too
sadly cirque du soleil yeah cirque du
soleil um
filed for bankruptcy and and shut down
their operations
well i think a lot of people file for
bankruptcy now and they're out of
business but once this
pandemic is over they'll regroup and
come out with another name and
get back into it again probably i did i
have friends at cirque du soleil i'm a
big circus guy
and uh apparently while the guy who
started his name was like god
guide to liberty or seminar the gee
somebody
and he sold cirque du soleil to a big
corporate entity
and now apparently with everything going
on in the pandemic
the original guy might be buying back
the circus which i think is a pretty
beautiful thing
yeah that's pretty cool that's pretty
cool so speaking of pandemic
have you done any of these drive-in
shows have you done any like what
what what's i opened for a friend of
mine
brad paisley in um in um nashville
in the parking lot of the nissan arena
and it was like 700 cars
and they would checkerboard park them so
that the people can get out and they
could stay in that square
in between the other three or four cars
and then they were masks so it was
all really you know well done and safe
and everybody on the stage you know
wear masks and you know stayed their
distance
but it was really interesting because
you know it's not like a comedy club
where you have a low ceiling and you
hear all the laughs
and the cars go all the way back you
know all the way back and people are
not even that close to the stage to
begin with and so you're kind of playing
to like a couple of groups
in the front row and you can't even hear
the rest
but you assume that they're laughing and
it takes a while for the lesser you
wait in between jokes wow and so when
when they laugh or they like flickering
their headlights or are they honking or
they
uh you know that was my big fear um
because i even get that in comedy clubs
uh they actually they're very uh they're
very uh curtis
uh courteous courteous yeah and they um
you know i think they beeped a couple
times when i was done you know just as
like an applause you know
yeah but it was really fun to watch that
you know and i have some videos of it
it's pretty cool
it's um it's it's i i don't know if
i i don't know i mean it'd be
interesting to have the experience
jim jeffries was telling us that they uh
the magic castle they did they're doing
it at the magic castle here
and i think the comedy store through the
comedy store or something magic castle
yeah you know who would have thought how
valuable parking lots would have been
yeah i think that they've been actually
the parking lot business has
has done well at all times
it looks like you've kind of been on
vacation for a couple of months in your
rv
yeah you're so chill you got your dog
laying on your lap there
obviously he trusts you yeah this is the
dog that i found in the streets of peru
really what were you doing in peru i was
mountain climbing
with uh the ufc hall of famer chuck
liddell
and a number of other uh personalities
it was a little bit like a mountain
climbing uh
operation motivated by dancing with the
stars
yeah i was sort of mountain climbing
with the stars and it's funny you should
say that because
literally minutes before i came in and
sat down to connect with you i was
watching free solo
oh wow i saw it in the theater twice
i just what if they could play that
against the wall of el capitan outside
but that's like a horror story for me
that's my that's my scariest horror
movie
is watching that yeah oh no i i get it
i mean that guy uh that guy that guy is
incredible i
i saw it in the theater twice and i
cried and they've never seen it once
it's an amazing it's like you know he's
not gonna die the whole time but it's
still
like i know i rewatch it and i still get
afraid you know it's like when i rewatch
the muhammad ali fight
you know like an old fight of muhammad
ali against foreign or something where i
know he loses
i'm still cheering him on yeah i'm
getting you got to get him
yeah right and i think it won the
the best documentary oscar if i'm not
mistaken
you know the thing that was frustrating
for me
which which maybe is is why he is so
successful at what he did
was that he didn't let his emotions take
him over
you know at the end i would have been
bawling like a baby at the top of that
you know right but he was like with his
girlfriend um don't say that
you might make me cry
right man do you know what you just did
you risked your life you scared
everybody
right and um you know you accomplished
it
yeah it's crazy how like
you know the and then the guy's the
guy's a hero for doing that in my view
he's a hero but he did
really risk his life i mean he's like
he's like an evil knievel
right right and then you know i don't
know if he saw anything about it but
but just a couple weeks ago i did this
publicity stunt that was
done i was duct taped to a billboard in
hollywood it couldn't have been more
safe you know it was the opposite of a
free solo
i was clipped on in five different with
five different carabiners
clipped with with with uh straps that
were rated for
5 000 pounds of weight and duct taped
i mean nothing could have possibly gone
wrong everybody everybody went crazy
what was what was the publicity stunt
for it was for i've
self-released a multimedia comedy
special on my own website it's very
explicit
and uh as i as i perform stand-up comedy
the stories i'm telling are
illustrated by actual footage which is
edited into it which i was pretty
excited about
and uh has it come out yet it's on my
website stevo.com yeah
no did that help the billboard stunt did
it help sell tickets
it did it it really did
and um i i invested a great deal of
money in that more than i've ever spent
on anything in my life
and uh and i got it all the back so it's
actually
in the profit zone and you bought this
rv
i actually bought the rv uh beforehand
but thank god because
so it was was the gist of it to see how
long stevo could stay
taped to the billboard before it lets
him lose
not before it lets me lose but it was
more of a
an exercise i thought it would either be
a very quick ordeal where
you know like the authorities show up
and and sort of put their foot down and
make it stop
or it would be a uh sort of a
you know a nod to david blaine where i
stayed up for like an
entire week which i was prepared to do i
went up there wearing a diaper
[Laughter]
how long were you up there about an hour
and 45 minutes
you still have a diaper on i i don't
still have it on now but i did
have it for the whole hour and 45
minutes yeah was this a billboard you
would rent it or did you just kind of
gorilla style
i did i went it was a bill it was a
billboard that i rented
and it said my name on it and everything
it said uh that my
very naughty multimedia special was
available at stevo.com said it right
there on the billboard
i'm gonna check it out i gotta check it
out man yeah hey man i'd be happy to
send you a secret screener link which i
sent to the to the media i'm really
quick i'll buy a ticket i'll buy a
ticket
i'll pay for it i'll watch it how about
that man i
i appreciate that a lot yeah i mean
you've been on the billboard you wear
diapers
right right right and um actually
um i can do it it will have already
happened but
um the uh the fire department showed up
and and i had my my construction team my
rigging team go straight to them and say
hey
this is very safe and we've got our own
cranes we can get them down at any time
and they said well we can't let that
happen so the fire department
quickly got me down and now because uh
you know because i just hate that they
had to do that
i've got a fundraising effort where i've
uh printed
many uh copies of this fantastic shot of
me on the billboard i'm signing them all
for
for charity it's kind of oh nice nice
were you fined not not uh
don't jinx it just yet
yeah there were no charges there were no
fines uh
so far so good i guess yeah i guess you
can't get a permit to take yourself to a
billboard huh well you can buy the
billboard
oh but you were renting it well right
i was renting it and uh there wasn't
anything in the rental agreement that
precluded me from doing what i did
i did have it looked over by it by an
attorney maybe they'll add that now
they'll like oh
you cannot attach yourself to this
billboard right
they were there a lot of people on the
ground watching
it showed up on the citizen app where uh
all of a sudden i got a notification on
my phone saying man duck takes himself
to a billboard and you look at it
and it's streaming 700 000 people
watching this i mean i think there was a
cumulative total at the end of the
ordeal 700 000 people had viewed it but
not all at once
i don't know it's kind of like free solo
but more like free stevo
right exactly yeah man we've we do i
love your comedy
you know uh you did that show at the uh
laugh factory
i believe it was on tuesday nights uh
with kevin nealon
there's a great format there's this uh
yeah new material night new material
network comics come in and they
they do a little bit of stand up try
some new stuff and then we sit down and
we
just kind of chat right yeah it was a
great format i remember at that time
ah god it was it's been it was probably
maybe 2013 and um
i had been you know touring with the
same material and i was just you know
you get in your comfort zone where
you're kind of reeling off the seam of
chill it gets a little bit stale a
little bit boring the experience of it
and i just made a deal with myself i'm
gonna
i'm gonna do 10 minutes new material for
better or for worse if it goes terribly
or
that whatever i'm just i put it on my
calendar i stuck to it and that was the
night when i
i came and performed with you and and i
had to do well that's cool
yeah i actually i got a bit out of our
uh
sit down chat that uh that i never
never even thought to do i'm glad i've
gotten so much material from that night
because you know it's it's more of a um
condensing what we used to do when we
were just starting out and stand up
where you
hang out in the clubs all night and then
you go to like cantor's deli or
something and sit down and just chat and
try and riff and come up with material
and you know now like we have families
and stuff we don't have that time so
it's kind of like a cliff notes of that
where you just do stand-up
and then you sit down and chat and then
that's it you know
yeah oh it was great and i've always
been that you know i've always admired
you too because you know coming from
jackass i thought oh this guy's just
like
this guy is like just really looking for
thrills you know because first he did
all that physical stuff and now he's
doing stand-up
and um but you always seem to like have
that
enjoyment factor that it's just you
loving what you're doing even if you're
hurting yourself you're loving this
but with this yeah with the stand up at
least you know now you're kind of more
focused in on
you know this type of a craft and it's
been fun to watch you
kind of your career well i appreciate
that a lot kevin
and you know i always say that in
everything i do i'm motivated by the
just pure attention whoring that's what
at the time uh
you know if there's such a thing as a
super [ __ ] you know that's how i
am and uh and and yeah it's like man
it's always
i've always appreciated your your
support you know coming from jackass and
then starting to do stand-up comedy
there's a little bit of uh of a sense of
self-consciousness where you know am i
going to be accepted by standard
comedians
you know i'm am i going to be accepted
by the people
uh you know by the fans are they gonna
sign off on this
and um you know i i didn't let it uh
slow me down i just kept going for it i
kept working hard and here i am
ten years into a comedy tour and uh so
grateful that i just
went for it yeah that's so awesome man
congratulations
i'm curious to go to the beginning of of
your career kevin like
we were watching you on carson and all
that what was that like being doing
carson
oh man it was really the highlight of my
career
you know more so than saturday live or
or weeds or any of those shows
man listening to kevin nelen describe
the highlight of his career you can just
tell it means so much to him
and you know what means so much to me
football's back baby
the nfl and i don't know what it's going
to be like
to watch the nfl during a pandemic but i
know for
darn sure that draftkings wants to give
you
a shot at winning millions in cash
prizes
that's right i teamed up with draftkings
to tell you about this offer
right now how does it work you go and
download the draftkings app
you use the promo code stevo you put
together your dream team
being careful to stay under the salary
cap all right
now when you make your first deposit you
automatically get a shot at winning
millions in cash prizes plus one
person's
definitely gonna win a full million
dollars
there's like so many millions okay
so again download the draftkings app put
together that
team and get ready to win are you ready
to win
yeah all right now kevin kneeling
because it's what i aspired to do was to
get on the tonight show with johnny
carson to be a stand-up
so you know when i first moved from
connecticut to los angeles
i you know i would hang out i was about
23. i would hang out at the comedy clubs
you know i lived at the improv
melrose pretty much and i became a
bartender there but i used to go
to the tonight show taping every a
couple times a week
in burbank and they would give out
tickets earlier in the day to people
they everybody got two tickets i knew
that
they weren't always using the tickets so
i go up and down the line says anybody
have an extra ticket
and i'd always get one because i was
alone and then i go in there it's like
watching a vegas show you know johnny
would come out i knew the exact
routine they did fred the corporate
producer would come out and
then johnny would come out and do a
little talk and and i knew all the you
know
the band members what they look like and
so
and as a comic you auditioned for that
show
you know several times at least before
you get accepted
and it's always the nerve-wracking when
the talent
uh you know coordinator is in the
audience the comedy club looking at
somebody else
because some comics don't want him to
see you because they don't feel like
they're ready yet you know
so but i remember auditioning for him a
couple of times and i would have sweat
coming out of me where it never came out
of me before like running down the back
of my legs
you know so in a nutshell what happened
was i have been doing stand-up for about
four years wow i mean from nothing
from first getting on stage and um
[Music]
he was also working for a mike nezmuth
comedy show sketch show
that he was uh casting and mike nezmuth
used to do the monkeys
and um and so i thought to myself well
i'm not gonna do what i think
is good for the tonight show because
obviously he didn't pick me before i'm
gonna do what i think
is really funny so i did a bit that i
used to do was the choices would you
rather
this or would you rather do that you
know
in the real gross you know choices which
is a game i you know we always do
growing up
and um and he calls me the next day he
said well good news and bad news
you're not right for the mike nezmus
show but i think you'd be great on the
tonight show with that bit
can you do it on monday and this was
like friday i thought
yeah yeah so from that minute on i was
going over that five minutes in my head
he's like we could be talking to each
other right now and you think i was
listening to you but really i'm going
over that act in my head
you know i'm going over my act i you
know it was you had to think about your
wardrobe what are you gonna wear
i remember seeing ted danson on there
once and he had these uh
khaki slacks on and a burgundy jacket
with a tie but that looks pretty cool i
think i'll wear that
so uh the day comes i go out there i
pull into the lot
i'm so scared i drive by johnny carson's
you know corvette or whatever was parked
in the spot
i walk in and i go into my green room
and i'm so nervous i'm so scared
and um i go into makeup before the show
starts and johnny stops by specs his
head and then he goes
good luck on a show today you know and i
go oh my god this is johnny carson
because at the time that was the only
talk show around really you know that
was like
that was the uh mean potatoes back then
so so i'm in my dressing room waiting
and waiting
i think michael landon was the lead
guest and then he uh
they get come and get me and they bring
me to the back you know by the curtains
and i said i can't believe i'm doing
this it's a show i came to watch so many
times in person and now i'm the one
behind the curtain
and i'm going over my act in my head and
the talent coordinator is trying to make
loosen me up you know he's dancing
around he's really a klutzy guy but he's
trying to make me laugh
and i'm focusing on my act and then
johnny you know the band stops they come
back from
commercial johnny starts introducing me
this next
gentleman just he's very absurd you know
and uh
he's i can't believe he's introducing me
and then the band plays that curtain
opens up
as i'm heading out to my mark on the
stage i completely went blank
i couldn't remember my act at all
nothing
and as soon as the last applause stopped
it came to me thank god
and i started doing my act and i was
getting laughs i was so excited
i hear johnny laughing behind me i was
so nervous i got caught in mouth
where my mouth got so dry like when i
smile
my lip would stick to my gum up there
you know
i didn't want to lick it because then i
think people know i'm nervous if i lick
it
and they'll have cotton mouth you know
so i just adjusted with the bottom lip
you know i rocked that up a little bit
you know i was doing everything i could
and i was getting applause breaks and it
ended
and i couldn't you know it was like i
was outside of my body thinking i'm
doing the tonight show right now with
johnny carson
and it ended and i thanked everybody you
know johnny gives me this thing and i
walk back to the curtains
and um he's back there the talent
coordinator and he's smiling he goes you
did great he did great he said stick
around i think johnny's going to want to
talk to you on the couch
wow no way doesn't that he said just
just rip it out there rip it you've got
plenty of stuff so he
he brings me back after the commercial
and we
chatted on the couch and you know i i
had a couple more strong jokes that i
used and
i've never had a felt a bigger natural
high than that
[ __ ] i bet before it aired and i was
praying there'd be
no you know disaster where it would be
preempted
you know and then i watched it at my
friend's house
uh he and his wife and um it was a bad
choice of outfits i looked like an usher
you know looked like a page
and and i knew because i hung out the
improv all the time that everybody at
the improv
would watch a comic on the tv over the
bar you know everybody would be quiet
and they especially was their first shot
on the tonight show and i knew they were
all down there watching
and to this day i still have um a take
from my voice message machine
of all the comics that called me and
said i'll kill how much i killed
we uh we heard you talking about
collecting
tapes from answering machines i do have
i do have some that i saved
it's mostly well yeah it's
that and um and also girlfriends that
would break up with me
i would save the tape and one time i
actually
used it because i had auditioned for a
mcdonald's commercial
and i had to cry and i just broken up
with a girl
an actress we go out for six months but
i was devastated i always got so
devastated when somebody
dropped you know let me go and so i go
in for this audition for mcdonald's
and it was for a big mac
and there was like four casting people
see it was like american idol the judges
they're sitting behind a table and i had
the script memorized and when it got to
the part where i had to cry
it was effortless and i started sobbing
like a baby i'm doing the lines they're
all like
god they were so bad for me
you know they believe it was so
believable because i was i was hurting
and so i got a call back like four weeks
later now i'm kind of over the girl
so i'm sitting outside and i brought her
eight by ten
with me and one of those voice recording
tapes of her breaking up with me
to try to bring it back wow but i
couldn't bring it back she screwed me
again
twice she screwed me yeah that's funny
yeah that's it
what year was it when uh when you did
that johnny carson for the first was
back in the 1900s
1984 and i do i still to this day i have
like i don't know if you do this on your
iphone
your messages if you have something
that's kind of endearing to you whether
it's family or friends
or even a celebrity you save the tape
and then you put it like on your ipad or
something the voice
so i have like i have hours of like
messages from people
my mother you know my mother died a
couple months ago and i
occasionally and ben and just listen to
her messages you know
i saved so that's pretty cool
yeah man you're one of the only people
that i know that actually like
hung out with andy kaufman what what was
he
was was he like how he was on the movie
when jim carrey played him or was he
different or or
how was he hanging out with him when you
when he did if you don't know about andy
kaufman
i'll tell you he was a crazy sob and you
know what else is crazy
how darned comfortable my bed is
because my mattress came from helix
sleep.com
and man sleep's important are you
getting enough sleep
and are you getting good enough sleep
because
i am telling you you're going to sleep
better if you go to
helix sleep.com
stevo where you can get up to 200
off of any mattress order plus
two free pillows with any mattress order
and dude these helix
sleep.com pillows are the most
comfortable thing in the world
so yeah i mean i just wanted to tell you
from my bed how darn comfortable
my bed is and how good i'm sleeping so
again get up to 200 off of any mattress
order
plus two free pillows if you go to helix
sleep.com stevo
that's right now let's hear about that
crazy sob
well you know i didn't really hang out
with him as a friend
i hung out with him because like i said
i would spend a lot of time at the
improv on melrose
i bartended there for two years and then
i just basically lived there to become a
comic
and so i saw everybody in there you know
i mean more you know robin williams
would come from doing morgan mindy and
his suspenders still on the buttons
they go right on stage and you know
steve martin and albert brooks
all these guys would come down there
yeah wow and um
and andy kaufman who was you know the
three guys that influenced me the most
to get in a stand-up
was steve martin albert brooks and andy
kaufman because they were
each so unique and they were they you
always had you guessing you know what
they were going to be doing next
so i would see him in there he's kind of
an odd guy and i i knew he was into tm
transcendental meditation wow so
outside of the improv one night he was
leaning against the wall
and i asked him i said hey andy i said
well
i'm thinking about getting into tm can
you tell me something about it
and that was like the perfect question
because he's just he just
talked about like a half an hour and i
was looking at
i was barely listening to what he was
saying i was just looking at his mouth
moving
and the moles on his face kind of you
know going up and down like slow motion
and uh but you know he was an
interesting guy you know he never knew
uh
what the first time i went to the improv
i was sitting you know at the bar
and i was looking in the mirror and to
my left was marty feldman
i don't know if you know him but he was
a great comic english british comic
and on my right was this guy who said he
was the original ronald mcdonald
clowns and uh turns out later he was he
was you know
messing with me he was um bob zumuda who
was andy kaufman's right-hand man oh
man he's like his idea guy he he
originally
was the ref in a lot of the wrestling
things yeah
in fact one time he called me and asked
if i would be a ref in one of andy
kaufman's
wrestling i think i had a gig that night
so i couldn't do it
wow probably better that way yeah
and then another thing i heard uh when
you when you came here
out of college did you really play
football were you really trying to be
the the punter or the kicker were you
the quarterback
i never played football in high school
but we played it um
neighborhood sandlot pickup games yeah
we had
shoulder pads and helmets and you know
we were serious about it and we would
play
these gangs from across town on the high
school football field like on a sunday
when nobody was playing
and we had no refs so it was just really
kind of a free-for-all
so i was a good player i had a good arm
and i was a good kicker
and my buddy comes to me one day this is
like um
i was just about ready to graduate
college he goes hey kev fairfield
university has a club football team
all you have to do is take a night
course to qualify to play on the team
you want to play i said yeah so we took
a course in criminology that we went to
three times
and we got on the team and the starting
quarterback got hurt so i got to be
quarterback
and it was like the time of my life and
and he was an offensive lineman and i
became the kicker
and the punter and it was a great season
they never won games before we started
winning games you know and then the next
spring season we go we go back there to
try out again the coach calls us and he
goes
guys you got to take 12 credits to play
i guess some of the other players were
complaining because they weren't getting
to play
we were like a couple of ringers you
know so
i wanted to do stand-up in la so
my my game plan was to come out here
i would i had like six usfl footballs
that was the league at the time it was
united states football league it was
similar to the nfl but
the balls are a little bit lighter and i
don't think maybe there was 90 yards
and um so i was practicing kicking at
fairfax high
like every day and i thought i'm going
to try out i'm going to be a walk-on
for the la express as a punter and that
would be a good gimmick for my stand up
too not only is it comic
but he's also the kicker the la express
give my hand you know
luckily my career started taking off
before there was tryouts
so i never ended up trying out for it
that's cool
and you started doing saturday night
live in 86
yeah 86 i never like
you know i all i wanted to do was stand
up that's all i didn't want to be an
actor
or you know a sketch player i just
wanted to stand up comedy that was my
thing
and occasionally saturday night live
would come rolling through la
looking for cast members you know lorne
michaels and their crew
and you had to have a really high
powered agent to get a
audition or they had to hear about you
or be with the groundlings or something
and so i i knew i'd never get on that
show and i never aspired to get on that
show i was like you know i thought wow
that's gotta be a crazy show to be on
at the time i was roommates with dana
carvey he kind of shared the apartment
garage when he was in town he rented
it he lived in san francisco and we used
to hang out a lot and see him in the
clubs and he got selected to be on the
show that summer
and he recommended me when he got there
and so uh that's how i got my audition
and he started
out as a writer started out that he
offered me a job as a writer and a
feature player
and guaranteed me seven shows out of the
22.
and so you know i just went there i had
to learn how to write sketches
and learn how to do characters and um
and i you know i basically i just wrote
myself into everything
so i was on every show and then the next
year they said you could stay a writer
and get the writing credit or you could
be a cast member and not get any writing
credit
so i said i'll take the cast member and
i kept writing like everybody does there
but i just wasn't getting credit after
that
was there a turning point where you
started to to really enjoy it like oh i
actually do like doing sketches and
writing these things and stuff like that
oh yeah i really enjoyed the opportunity
i enjoyed um
living in new york city and you know
working with all these great people
every week
but um i remember the first sketch i did
was mr subliminal
insert words into my dialogue and try to
get people to see it my way you know
and i remember right before i was about
to go on
here i'm at 30 rock you know i'm in
studio 8h and it's
saturday night live people are the
bleachers and it's now my turn to do my
sketch
five seconds away coming out of
commercial lorne michaels the producer
comes up to me and he puts
his hand on my shoulder and he goes are
you sure this is what you want
wow but it was a thrill for me i loved
doing it and i loved writing
and um i became really good at writing
sketches and coming up with characters
and
it was a real thrill for me i did it for
nine seasons is it true that lorne
michaels like uh you'll get fired if you
kind of break character and laugh or get
out of scene or is he pretty
relaxed about that fire but he really he
looked down upon that
he thought it was really hacky it was
kind of like the carol burnett show
when um you know those guys would break
character which was funny at the time we
always like to see that
but i think it got to a point like none
of us hardly any of us
did it you know i never did it maybe
once with chevy chase and we can update
but i mean i did the the chris farley
chippendale sketch
patrick swayze you were a judge right
yeah i was a judge yeah
so um but then i started seeing people
then we
started bringing other people in like
spade would come on and farley and you
know spade would laugh
start laughing a lot and you know
sandler sometimes a break character
but then i noticed as time went on
different casts
were almost using it to get laughs it's
almost like
you know and that's what lord didn't
like about it he thought let's rely on
the material to get less
and not rely on you know
yeah sure i know what that's like for
sure
yeah when you use that as a crutch like
yeah it's uh it is funny to watch and
see that if it happens
rarely right but if it's happening every
week
with this kind of the same people you're
thinking oh man this is not
this is i get the lauren thing you know
right i saw something that you said
and and uh it sounded like earlier in
your career you were interested in doing
impressions like in your stand-up yeah i
mean i always in high school i loved
doing impressions you know i thought i i
used to love
watching impressionists on tv
and um you know rich little and um
some of these other people i mean i
thought it was so cool the way somebody
could like
turn their face into looking like
somebody and contact them
so i would do all the standard ones back
then like you know
there's a long time ago it's like jimmy
stewart and john wayne
and um but then i thought do i want to
be doing
impressions of other people or do i want
people to be doing impressions of me
yeah
so i thought i want people to do
impressions of me and that hasn't
happened yet so that might have been the
wrong route
wow that's great yeah that and i mean i
can
see that had to maybe help with the
characters and stuff with saturday night
live
you know if you've got this this talent
for impressions it's gotta
well the the happy gilmore impressions
that people do or the
the grandma's boy did you write your own
character for that
or did no that was already kind of
established
but i would embellish it and improvise
on it and we would just run with it you
know feel the flow harness the good
block the path yeah
yeah the diamond parasol goes round and
around and round
wow then the ball at home yeah
feel it yeah i mean it's pretty awesome
like
that just it's never slowed down for you
huh that it really hasn't it's you know
it's never been like skyrocketing
but it's always been kind of like this
kind of a grade yeah
circular circular
and when did weeds start
you know the funny thing about weeds was
i i had done snl for nine seasons i left
to do a sitcom which is highly touted it
was with dreamworks
and it lasted maybe eight episodes
and then two years later i got another
highly touted uh epis uh
sitcom with imagine tv brian grazer
with uh with richard lewis and um
uh eugene levy and you know it should
have been a great hit
and again too many cooks in the kitchen
and it got deluded and it lasted like
maybe eight episodes and i started
thinking myself i wonder if i'll ever
do a show that'll be as exciting as
saturday night live
or doing the first tonight show you know
and then
i got a script delivered to me it was
called weeds and i thought oh man i've
seen
so many of these stoner movies and
scripts you know and i read i thought
wow this is different
the characters are great the story's
good the writing is good
and so i auditioned for it and i got the
part
and um and it was just a guest star in
the pilot and i shot
that and um and i kind of forgot about
it
and then i remember i was at the beach i
got a phone call from my agent he goes
remember that pilot you did like two
months ago
well it got picked up for series of
showtime and they want you to be a
regular cast member
that's sweet wow sweet so um that was a
nice it's that's the thing about this
business sometimes things come along
unexpectedly
you know and um and that's the
excitement of it too
when you do a show like weeds or you
know with with a lot of marijuana
involved dude does anybody
ever really smoke marijuana on the set
you know during the filming or
just it's all [ __ ] and it's good
i don't think there'd be a show if they
did yeah yeah
a lot of it's it's um it's called honey
herb
is what we smoke it's a very gentle herb
that they roll into a joint or cigarette
but still if you're not a smoker
it makes your throat it burns your
throat out you know and i remember after
doing the pilot
i remember in the pilot i was sitting in
an suv with mary louise parker
and valencia it was like 101 degrees and
they can't run the ac
when they're shooting because of you
know the audio
so it was so hot i was smoking they did
so many takes on smoking and smoking it
and i woke up that night thinking
oh my god did i give myself throat
cancer just for a stupid pilot that
never been picked up
but you know for eight years there was a
lot of that smoke in that um honey
reserve and it was a little potent too
because we got it from the honey rose
herb cartel in colombia
you know what i'm saying right yeah
man it's uh the with the saturday night
live
they talk about a saturday night live
curse where
you know people become such like like
household names and then they're out of
control with drugs and alcohol
but but that's never been your story no
no no never have you never had that in
fact when i was on
our cast was i think pretty clean i mean
there were some family people like phil
hartman was married
um dennis miller was married i think at
the time and
none of these people were you know doing
drugs or even drinking that much really
and then we the cast started getting
bigger you know then farley came on
and um and you know things started
getting a little
little shakier than the younger people
and
i remember farley came by my dressing
room once and he's kind of strung out
he's knocking on sandler's dressing room
door and i started talking to him but
you know you you really can't control
somebody or you know steer them in one
direction but i
i said what do you what are you up to
what are you up to farley what's going
on
uh you know it's partying and i said
[Music]
i forget exactly how i ordered it but we
got into a discussion of you know
are you really being as funny as you can
when you're that you know
high on drugs and and you know and then
recovering and all that stuff he goes
well
you know john belushi used to do drugs
and he wanted to be just like john
belushi
of course and uh in every way he says he
was his idol
and uh belushi died of 33 and uh farley
died at 33. wow
you know the same thing and um but every
time i would see farley
we'd always have this little connection
where you'd see me be talking to some
people they'd be laughing you know
and then you see me take it down a notch
take it down a notch
but you know i was like a little bit
older than those guys like spade and
sandler
and rock and uh
farley and they'd always be in another
wing of the writers
you know level floor you'd have to go
down a hallway and get to their place it
was almost like a dorm like a college
dorm
and i go down there and i felt like the
teacher sometimes i walk in there and
they're like there's food everywhere
there's you know like pizza boxes on the
floor and you know playboy
you know magazines and pictures
everywhere and then talking about who
they slept with the night before and
um but then there was chris rock's
office which is right off that one
and that was impeccable it was like so
tidy and he had like malcolm x posters
on the wall
and you know martin luther king so he
kind of had it he
i think he was amused by what was going
on outside of his office though
wait did you see david spade sleeping
with people
that doesn't sound right
[Laughter]
david spade is really charming in fact
when i first got on snl
i you know i knew him from stand up he
uh subletted my room in this house that
i had in the hollywood hills
so he was subletting from me in the
hollywood hills
and then he got on the next year so
another guy who screwed me over
yeah i had no one to rent my room
anymore but uh he's a very charming man
if he's
he's great yeah he just has stories and
he's so
self-deprecating you can't help but like
him yeah absolutely and and we have a
mutual buddy in
in uh legendary skateboarder tony hawk
you know
david spade is a fairly avid skateboard
guy
oh really i didn't know that yeah nick
watson too
i saw david spade in a skate shop
like he was like trying to get a board i
loved it i think
i think nick swardson's more like
buddies with skaters and a fan of
skating
but david spade will actually ride oh
that's cool wow
i never knew that i think i think uh i
think i got that right
yeah i don't know man i did i did a hike
with him stevo and um
it took me about a year to get them
uh-huh because it's got to be flat
it's got to be a flat hike otherwise i
can't do it and we got to go between
rush hour traffic because i don't want
to get stuck in rush hour traffic and i
got to have some food
because i'm hypoglycemic so there's so
many stipulations you know yeah
so you know like but i guess if you grew
up with a skateboard he's probably used
to that
yeah for sure yeah the hiking thing is
is great and and you're still doing that
it seems like you do it in seasons so
yeah i mean i never started off uh
thinking of seasons you know i just did
a hike with matthew modine
sacked her yeah birdie yeah
yeah full metal jacket and uh we i just
had my phone in my hand and i was just
recording them you know
and um i started i posted it on my uh
instagram and then twitter just like a
minute two minutes and people started
liking it so i thought i'll hike with
somebody different every week so i just
hired all my friends you know and
and i would post like three or four
different bits from the hike
and then i did howard stern once because
you should do a longer version of that
you know
that's a good idea so i started youtube
channel and then you know i'm hiking
i've done like 30
hikes i'm thinking maybe i should end
the season you know so i'm not like
trying to keep up
you know with heights just call this
season one and then start banking some
hikes
you know and get some better equipment
and then start season two like in
september
so that's what i did but it's cool
because i never started off like
thinking okay there'll be seasons
it was all of it it was very organic
it's good
and uh and what's going on lately like
was like what are we promoting right now
well i have this live stream uh comedy
uh uh show
september 12th on rushtix.com is where
people can get their tickets i think
they're ten dollars right now but
they're gonna go up soon
once i announce my special guest opener
um
so that's coming up and um and i'm also
taking that um
hiking show and we're turning it into
like a
curb type of a show you know where it's
based around the hikes
the family life and we've been pitching
that and we've gotten some good bites on
that too so
yeah we might be playing that soon wow
cool and uh and you've got two books
you're you're an author right there um
well i have one book it's called yes
you're pregnant but what about me
because when my wife was pregnant 13
years ago she was getting all the
attention
and i wasn't so yeah yeah you're
pregnant what about me don't i get uh
you know
some attention what about whelmed but
not overly
that was a stand-up special i have two
stamp specials oh i thought it was a
book for some reason okay
oh shoot was it but not overly that was
the one that had the incredible
uh ski mountain bit in it yeah yeah
oh my god opening is so good is that
like i mean i've seen a lot of your of
your comedy but the bit about the ski
mountain
is that like the the
the one that just got the most heat
yeah i think it went viral i think from
the conan show
but that was one of those bits that i
had like
in my pocket for a long time i thought
this was too easy it's gotta be two
it's so good and then one day i just
started working on it and throwing it
out there and it just kind of took off
and people loved it especially in ski
areas you know colorado and stuff they
dig
so yeah i have that whelmed but not
overly and then um
hear me out now hear me out yeah that's
the other one
that was based on a joke um you know
when somebody says now hear me out
you don't want to hear the mouth like
now hear me out i'm going to lower you
into the well by your ankles
no no no no hear me out
i'm going to be poking you with a with a
barbecue
with a brand iron hear me out here
right yeah okay there's there's other
things like that too when uh
somebody says you know like no offense
but
yeah yeah with that said
the other thing i'm excited about stevo
i don't know about you but during the
pandemic you kind of find out what you
really enjoy doing a lot because you
have a lot of free time and mine is like
i love to draw so i've been drawing a
lot of caricatures
yeah yeah we saw that on youtube on your
instagram you've got some
really incredible art thanks buddy and i
have one instagram just totally
dedicated to that it's called kevin neal
and artwork
okay and um and i've really been having
a lot of fun doing that
all right well i just got on your uh
your kevin neal and instagram i'm going
to add the kevin neal and
artwork too man sweet i love it i love
that dog man that dog loves you
she's the best man she is does she speak
english
um she's bilingual she's she's a little
uh
fickle she'll she knows what she does uh
whether you know what kind of what she
wants but then she must have her
uh yeah yeah she's a big fan of scott
randolph over here
so when you did the uh that nissan
center
in nashville you said the uh it sounds
like the the actual performing the
comedy was
very very uh conservative very safe from
the masks the cars
but what about the flight out there how
did how did you feel about that
well i flew with the uh performer so
it's private
oh how about that yeah yeah but even
that was kind of you know the pilots
were quarantined
for a long time and they had their covet
test
before we went on right masks on and we
had masks
uh we've now matched the whole time
because we've been potting with it with
them you know
so we're our our kids are good friends
so they spend a lot of time together
so you know it all worked out it felt
perfectly safe
but um it's interesting now that a lot
more people are wearing masks
and i don't want to become that mask
nazi but when i see somebody not wearing
a mask
i think man that's so like disrespectful
yeah yeah i actually started selling
masks
i got yeah yeah i've added it into my
merch line i've got
here's uh that's that's my um
you know my steve with my big obnoxious
teeth and then i got
another one that's a little bit naughty
which
uh you know i filled my mouth with
dishwasher soap
it's dirty and clean
yeah you see so so you go around wearing
that
and and uh you know that way you're not
disrespectful
you wear this they can be respectful and
what when you did jackass did you lose
any of your teeth
ah not from not from jackass
but uh yeah i got i got a couple teeth
on my little retainer thing right here
that's from meth yeah yeah
i was never a big fan of meth but of
course i never turned it down
[Laughter]
you have to take that out every night
when you go to bed i don't have to but i
do
just when he smokes meth
did you play hockey at all i i didn't i
didn't play hockey now
but uh i just said i was predisposed to
to poor um you know dental health
i don't know got a floss yeah i don't
know okay so i want to get this again
one more time this uh you said it's
september 12th
september 12th 7 p.m pacific standard
time 10 o'clock eastern time
people can get their tickets on rush
ticks r-u-s-h-t-i-x
dot com and um it's it's an hour stand
up i have an opener
and i'll be sitting right where i am
right now but i might get a green screen
and um do something maybe a little fancy
and tricky
with it yeah the other question was
will you be sitting down or standing up
right and
albert brooks told me he said you should
probably stand up
if you're doing a stand-up yeah and so
i'd have to push the computer back
right get a green screen maybe with like
curtains
and then have a stool with glass of
water and
i don't know that seems like a lot of
work doesn't it yeah but but you're
kevin neeland so you should probably be
kneeling while you do so okay
all right man yeah you got it still
i love it oh my god um
yeah but i'm excited about it and um you
know we're we're selling tickets and
my like i said my special guest is gonna
be opening for me he's not a comic
per se but he's gonna uh be a big draw
good exciting i i like that so we'll
send everybody to
for the moment kevin nealon on instagram
i assume that's going to be where uh the
reveal is of the guest's identity
yeah yeah yeah um also rushtix.com
and you know the great thing about the
pandemic too is even though i haven't
been working out in clubs
as you know you've been gathering a lot
of you know material and
areas as my friend calls it when you
don't have punch lines right there are
areas those are good areas
to you know explore a little more so i
have a whole
like you know list of funny things that
i would have been working out in the
clubs if i
if they were you know available so i'm
excited about it i mean
your whole approach to stand up is so
unique i mean really
and every time i've ever seen you in the
club i
i just can't say enough about how
thoroughly i enjoy you
i really i really do man i really do so
uh
and everybody's got to see this this uh
september 12th
performance the question uh for me
less about whether you stand or sit is
do you plug a microphone in
i think or you know maybe the sound yeah
there will be a microphone yeah
holding a microphone in your hand
however you're uh
positioned i think that that that's
that's what stand-up's about for me a
little bit
yeah that sells it man that sells it i'm
gonna have a waitress
walk in front of
yeah me absolutely love it well hey man
um you know good luck with the the
september 12th thing thank you so much
for uh
for doing this with us really thank you
steve thanks for having me buddy i
really appreciate it thanks for taking
the time
dude you're a legend and uh the honor is
ours
um maybe we'll get to do one of those
hikes one time man
yeah absolutely man i'd love that yeah
you know once they start them up again
yeah i know it took a long time to get
spayed it's
taking a little longer with me
i'll meet you in the middle all right
bring your tooth with you yeah
i will brother thank you so much kevin
all right thanks you guys thanks kevin
take care dude not just a legend of
comedy
he's just a legend as a dude man i
really like him
and i like you for sticking around this
long
as always the street team please let
kevin neal and know that
you enjoyed the show and check out that
thing he's got in two days september
12th
yeah make sure that you do that and i
love you guys and
i'm getting back in my helix bed